um
you've kind of alluded to that you're
very opinionated i mean you're loud
you're
does that getting get you into trouble
today like i like i've i've caught a
very strong feeling about a lot of
silicon valley and tech guys and even
entrepreneurs that lean very far left
and it's like if you express an opinion
like for example let's use the will
smith slap you know from the other day
because i know that you you know do some
work you know with the academy and
setting up parties and stuff like that
what was your view of the will smith
slap stupidity
absolutely
or on smith's part
um smith smith smith 100 yeah look at it
ellen tina fey uh ricky gervais for
christ's sake have you ever watched any
of his monologues for like the golden
globes and
what chris rock did it was a pretty mild
joke
it was it was a very mild joke okay and
jada let's be blunt she looks absolutely
fantastic with her hair she's got a
beautiful face okay and
they are actors and actresses for
christ's sake they live for attention
and chris gave it to him
okay
and what did what it will do
will is probably one of the nicest guys
out there i will say that you know
unfortunately i i've worked with him a
couple of times
but the way he he markets and brands
himself he's always branded as one of
the nicest guys out there he's always
funny now
that's a lot of that is an act because a
lot of the time you don't want to be fun
and friendly it's bloody work but he
does a fantastic job at it
and now he's just [ __ ] on his good guy
image so
part of me thinks
will stupid the other part of me think
damn what happened man for that split
second
you lost it you lost control and you did
something stupid and of course we're now
seeing the backlash and we're now seeing
that all the apologies and all these
kind of stuff
as tough that's totally aware so here's
my question when it comes back into the
loud opinion so
i share the same opinion as you right
but i mean there's a lot of people out
there that uh
gave will smith a standing ovation when
he slapped chris rock for the mild joke
um you know some people have said that
that was a setup because the show
doesn't draw eyeballs anymore and they
wanted to manufacture indignation to
draw attention to it like
how do you deal with the heat from
people when you have a loud vocal
opinion on subject matters like this
beautiful you don't you see there are
three kinds of people in the planet and
one of them is terrible and they're
terrible because it's your fault okay
line this up anyone out there with a pen
and paper or you know record this or
whatever make a note of this
there were three kinds of people they
were the kind of people that absolutely
love you i guarantee you during this
this live feed that we're doing there
are people that love the way i am my
attitude my style they absolutely love
it yeah that's brilliant
i guarantee you there's also people on
this feed that are probably left going
rich you shouldn't have got this guy on
can't understand what he's on about i
don't like the guy
both of those are good because they
saved me the effort i don't want to try
and get someone that hates me into my
corner and i want that
here's the third people
the fence sitters
those people that are sitting on the
fence going
i'm not sure about this guy you know
what's he trying to say you know i don't
know what he stands for um i'm confused
about this guy those are the fence
sitters those are the worst people in
the planet and nine times out of ten
you've created them now if i'm out there
and i'm saying [ __ ] about something or
if i'm talking about branding or if i'm
talking about speaking engagements or
i'm talking about you know my opinion on
the will smith slap or the the the
british empire screwing up a marketing
opportunity if i'm saying that it allows
those fences to go oh i agree with him
or oh my god i hate him
and i want to be able to push those
people off onto one side or the other i
don't want to take any effort
in trying to be someone i'm not
my effort is there to be able to work
with the people that i choose to work
with to be able to solve your problem
it's never going to be on how i come
across oh i've got to dilute this oh
i've got to be a bit careful i'm not
selling hamburgers i'm not a mass market
product so i don't care
have you have they tried to cancel you
for anything like have they come at you
for anything
every now and then i'll say something
and and i run events and every now and
then i'll get i'll get something because
i may have you know
said
said the wrong word or two or ten um
but no because no one's ever really
tried to attack me
actually let me rephrase that
i've not recognized those people trying
to attack me because if you ever noticed
it was funny because doing the kind of
things i was doing and the concierge
industry i was always working with
incredibly affluent people and i would
get a lot of hate mail going how do you
sleep at night you know and oh you're
dealing with these people and you should
be putting your attention to charities
and you should be doing this and stuff
those people will never be my clients
those people will never work with me
therefore i can't hear you you know now
if if you've got jean-paul de jour your
wheel must turn around going hey sims
why are you doing that yeah i'll pay
attention now you're listening now i'm
listening i i've been saying that for
years
yeah always always consider the source
of the criticism yeah yep
um now to kind of to kind of challenge
you on that um three types of people
that you just mentioned i have a note
here about
um how how you've mentioned that you
should focus on your unsubscribers
yes are essentially your detractors and
previously you know you just said i
can't hear them they don't matter to me
they're never going to be my customers
so can you kind of explain what you mean
about focusing on your unsubscribers
yeah so what i've done is uh
it started off just as a
just as a test
really you know um
i would again i get a lot of people that
i do coaching and branding with but
every now and then i'll get people say
something and then unsubscribe or cancel
me or walk away but they've made a
comment they vocalized it the first
thing i would do is look at the source
you know and if you find out that you're
getting [ __ ] on from a 15 year old from
the philippines you don't care but if
it's a business owner and if rich cooper
is actually saying something that he
doesn't agree and steve you're way off
track and you're out
then i want to come to you and i'm going
to mitch i saw that it triggered you so
much
that not only did you vocalize you moved
off you unsubscribed
i i've got nothing to gain from this
other than the education of
understanding why i would love to
understand your perspective
now no one ever goes for those people
no one ever talks to the unsubscribers
no one ever talks to the haters they
always say oh you know you've got to be
so successful you get haters and you
should leave it alone
i can't
i absolutely love to get into that and
so
you would be surprised and i i don't
know the exact figure but i would say a
good 30
of my coaching and branding clients
came from people that argued about my
methods or my positioning or my style
that then came back to me once we had
that conversation they said you're right
yeah you see what you do
any relationship you want
you have to have a trigger
now when you see your mate that tells
good jokes you see him walk down the
street you're enlightened to see him
because you know that during the
conversation with him he's going to say
something funny and entertain you and
you see someone else and you hate them
you don't want to be anywhere near them
you want to create a trigger now if you
could take that trigger and convert it
into a positive one and nine times out
of ten miscommunication
now you said about have i ever been
cancelled have i ever been attacked all
the time and i made a flippant statement
which i shouldn't have said i said to
you that i don't get cancer because i
don't care i care enough to care about
who i am and what i say
and that will attract those people that
can see i may get it wrong but if i want
to come to you and go hey why do you
think that you know what have i said
this triggered you what was it that you
disagreed with and the amount of times
i've actually spoken to people i've gone
do you know you're right you're right
i'm wrong and i've actually done a
re-edit i've gone back and got it i
spoke to johnny
and he the genie brought my attention to
this
con
i want to become educated and that again
is down to that growth
of being the dumbest person in the room
and constantly be prepared to get
educated but first of all where's the
source hey guys i really hope that you
enjoyed that short clip if you did
consider supporting the creation of
content by checking out my supplement
line pinned in the top comment below of
this video in the comments there's a
link to the unplugged alpha dot com
forward slash shop when you click
through you'll be able to land over here
and the entire lineup is broken down by
category that it performs best in
estrogen metabolism fat burning your
foundational essentials for health
immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model where regular shipments will be
sent over to you on a regular basis and
that gives you a little bit of a
discount and your supplement facts are
always broken down over here thanks for
watching i hope you guys have an awesome
day and again check out that link it's
pinned in the top comment below in this
video peace out
you